on
[Musique]
va tout de suite retrouvez comme tous
les soirs jean yves lafesse les truites
pour la rubrique la fesse dans la rue et
aujourd'hui ce soir jean-yves il a
décidé de faire une prise de température
en direct
se vendait ce que vous avez une idée de
la température qui fait aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui quelle température il fait
un degré fait
d'accord c'est tout frais dans la bouche
bien
en direct à paris
et
assuré que nous allons approcher 36,5 à
36,7 à 36 madame fait un superbe effort
je pense que ces deux compacts et
concentré hulu c'est faire un petit 37 2
le matin à l'angle de la rue si le roi
ont riposté donc une belle tentative
entre prénom sans relâche et à me battre
la belge catherine jacques deen puisque
nous sommes actuellement à 36 une oreca
sera pas frileux des prix 37 je vais
vous demandez donc à lever d'efforts
dans quelques secondes
jacqueline g qui nous évite la réponse
mais j'ai tout mangé du quartier mais
bon donc
à un petit 37 attention 37 ine il est
donc 10h15 madame un début de goutte au
nez également de ses patients
l'asim de froid c'est une normale et
donc
tentative de mouchoir sur le nez voilà
un projet qui semble apprendre madame
jacqueline donc alors il est 10 heures
du matin à l'angle de la rue poncelet et
jacqueline pas se détrompent 18 à 37 de
ses bons parfait c'est sur cet exploit
de chaque connexion beauté et
spectateurs à regret aujourd'hui 10
heures du matin à l'angle de la rue
poncelet jacqueline a fait un petit
bravo jacques guine bravo j'espère vous
n'en êtes en train de regarder vous
faire un gros bisou il avait été
fantastique
[Musique]